let's go down to Cassie Delora for Blake
Shelton's sentimental send-off
yeah it was an emotional and
star-steaded night as Blake Shelton says
goodbye to the
for good but a cell atory one for Niall
Horan who took home his first win as
coach
you beat your TV dad but you did share a
special hug with him did he say anything
to you he said I taught you everything
you know that's what he that's not even
a joke it was such a special night for
him but it was also a fantastic to kick
that man out the door
and straight to an epic after party
where the nine-time winning coach was
met with a big surprise
wife Gwen Stefani had to skip the live
taping because of a prior out of town
commitment but arrived just in time to
celebrate Blake's 23 season run
[Music]
find my soulmate it's hard for me to
even talk about it without getting super
emotional it's been the greatest thing
that's ever happened to me in my life
inside the wrap party Blake's fellow
coaches had a blast Kelly Clarkson spent
her night on the Dance Floor while Niall
and chance socialized and I just sit in
my chair for the the last episode I'll
ever do the boys
6 million tuned in to watch the show
that was filled with video tributes
Blake I love you man
plus performances by CeeLo Green and
Maroon 5 featuring Blake's OG Buddy Adam
Levine the last show you've had a great
run don't screw it up you idiot just
kidding and a reunion of past Team Blake
members
[Music]
so what's next it's time with the fam
but is there a chance we could see him
back in the fall maybe we can get you
back as a mentor when Gwen's back
well Blake let's roll the tape because
here's what you said in December oh my
God to be honored to be winds Mentor
whatever she tells me to do I'm gonna do
Gwen will be joined by reigning champ
Nile voice vet John Legend and of course
Blake's replacement Reba McIntyre I'm
really excited nine-time coach Kelly
Clarkson is taking season 24 off to take
her talk show from LA to NYC
foreign